welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have a
new bombshell report about Marvel
variety of just gone for the head with a
big article detailing all the issues at
Marvel Studios and the drama behind the
scenes that's plaguing the MCU
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down and going through
the key points whilst also giving our
thoughts on it now the Marvels is
obviously out in less than two weeks so
this is a PE nightmare for the studios
to deal with however I'm being positive
I actually think that some light at the
end of the tunnel and I'll be talking
about why this is probably going to be a
good thing everyone out there everyone
who lived through the Clone SAA you know
fine well that Comics have these low
points however it seems like the studio
are actually aware of this and working
behind the scenes to try and fix the
damage now if you enjoyed the video
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day you also have our
coverage of Loki coming up so definitely
stay locked in cuz you don't want to
miss it without the way huge thank you
for clicking the video now let's get get
into this major report put put not
intended there so it comes from Variety
in leads with a headline is Marvel in
trouble man man bust out the graphic
design department and got a drawing of
audiences walking away from the current
main characters representing how fans
have turned their backs on the studio
now this is something that we've seen in
the box office and the declining
viewership of the Disney Plus shows the
Marvel is also set to be the lowest
grossing MCU film postco era and it
might even end up with the same opening
weekend as the Incredible Hulk now
because of this a lot of Panic setting
in they're definitely over marketing it
and shoving out lots of clues about who
could be showing up if you've read the
spoilers you know who that is we're not
going to talk about it here but the
article opens by saying this past
September a group of Marvel creatives
including Studio Chief Kevin fige
assembled in Palm Springs for the
Studio's annual Retreat most years
survive would have been confident even
cocky given how the premier superhero
brand owned by Disney since 2009 has
remade the entertainment business in its
image but this occasion was an ridden
everyone at Marvel was reeling from a
series of disappointments on screen a
legal Scandal involving one of its
biggest stars and questions about the
viability of the Studio's ambitious
strategy to extend the brand Beyond
movies into streaming the most pressing
issue to be discussed at the retreat was
what to do about Jonathan major the
actor who'd been poised to carry the
next phase of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but instead is headed to a
high-profile trial in New York later
this month in case you don't know these
Retreats they're coming at the studio
and normally they've gone there planned
out the phases Age of Ultron Infinity
War endgame all the big moves were made
there but this painted out as them being
in panic mode then says at the Gathering
Palm Springs Executives discuss backup
plans including pivoting to another
comic book adversary like Dr Doom but
making any ship would carry its own
headaches Mages was already a big
presence in the MCU including as the
scene stealing antagonist in February's
Antman in the wasw Mania and he has been
poised as the franchise's next big thing
in the season of Loki particularly in
the finale which airs on November 9th
this sets Kang up as the titular star of
the fifth Avengers film in
20126 Marvel is truly effed with the
whole K angle says one top dealmaker
who's seen the final Loki episode lucky
guy and they haven't had an opportunity
to rewrite until very recently because
of the wga strike but I don't see a path
to how they move forward with him now
the article also goes on to say they
were planning to go in another Direction
even before the drama because of how
much Quantum Mania underperformed hot
take right but I actually think Jonathan
majes was the best part of that movie
and I still regularly watch that scene
with him and Michelle Fifer fixing up
his chair he was also so incredible as
he who remains and he stole the show in
the lowkey season one finale I also
don't really think that Maes has caused
any issues with the Loki season 2
viewership and though that's down I
don't think it's because of him however
one thing I never got was why they were
putting him up for Secret Wars when Kang
was never the villain associated with
that story in the comics in case you
don't know the comics have Dr Doom as
the baddy in both versions of Secret
Wars with them getting the powers of a
God after killing the Beyond or
beyonders in the Hickman run either way
I actually think they could do something
narratively where they said Kang up is
the Beyond and then have Doom take the
power from him there were rumors a while
back that Kang would be the beyonder as
well so this would be a great transition
over into that just never made sense to
me to have Secret Wars without Doom as
then it kind of makes it pointless to
bring him into the MCU these are
probably his two biggest stories I know
there's other ones but they're probably
his two biggest ones and you could build
them out from a Fantastic Four film at
the moment it doesn't seem like they're
doing that either so it just made no
sense to bring Doom in at all would be
like having Iron Man do the Gwen Stacy
story with the Green Goblin before he
then brings Spider-Man in or or giving
House of M to someone like doctor
strange it's just weird now I've kind of
skirted around what's going on with
Mages in the past and I think that the
studio at this point just don't know
what to do so far they've LED with a
policy of silence and I've just wanted
to see how things play out however if
the trial's going ahead it's going to
get a lot of publicity and this will
happen while he's also shooting elements
of upcoming films so it just seems risky
because one day you'll have like
Jonathan Maes onset doing this and then
next day it's like Jonathan majes does
very bad stuff but potentially if that's
found in core so therefore they just
might want to play it safe and not even
take the risk building an entire phase
around a character like this was always
going to be risky and they might see the
risk not being worth the reward it's
clear that other projects of panic 2 as
Major's big Oscar movie that got a 5
minute standing ovations being pushed
back as well that means that it's
probably not going to be an Oscar
contention and yeah for that to be the
case it just shows the studios aren't
that confident I'm always trying to be
innocent until proven guilty but I can
totally see from a business point of
view that it might just want to make a
backup plan in case anyway the article
then goes on to talk about the four
weeks of re-shoot that the mar Mar s had
now normally foggy schedules these into
production and the re of Marvel Studios
book actually goes into this in Fair
detail it talks about how they'll put
together a script go film it and come
back and figy will give them notes from
here they'll then do certain things to
alter the direction and then go back for
reshoots to implement those changes it's
a strategy that's worked time and time
again but now due to all the content FY
stretched too thin he hasn't had the
time to oversee everything and to make
matters worse near the cost wasn't
present for the Marvel's re-shoot either
now I know this is getting downplayed
because she was away on another project
and it's possible that Marvel just took
over the Reigns and said look we have it
from here however four weeks is a big
chunk of the film like a third of it so
not having the director there to
actually shape their Vision it doesn't
look good dust has been pretty open
about how Marvel rule the Roose and I
feel a lot of the time she's just trying
to get in front of this story the
article then says if you're directing a
250 million movie it's kind of weird for
the director to leave with a few months
to go the Marvels has seen its release
date move back twice too once to swap
with Quantum Mania which was deemed
further along and again when its debut
shifted from July to November to give
filmmakers more time to Tinker but that
extra time didn't necessarily help in
June Marvel witch traditionally only
solicits feedback from Disney employees
and their friends in families took the
uncharacteristic step of holding a
public test screening in Texas the
audience gave the f middling reviews
they should call it the midels the midc
anyway the article then backs up our
prior point before saying but Marvel has
never been in the business of being
average Kevin's real superpower his
genius has always been in post-
production in getting his hands of
movies and making sure they're finished
strongly The Source adds these days he's
spread thin and then says FY declined to
comment and then says five years and the
only person showing signs of strain
Marvel's entire V effect Battalion
including staffers and vendors is
struggling to keep Pace with a never
ending stream of Productions this past
February when credits rolled at the
world premiere of quantum Mania shock
rippled through the regeny Village
Theater in Westwood over some shy CGI
there were at least 10 scenes where the
visual effects had been added at the
last minute and they were out of focus
says one veteran power broker who was
there it was insane I've never seen
something like that in my entire career
everyone was talking about it even the
kids of executives are talking about it
the schedule swap with the Marvels had
left the Ant-Man sequel in a squeeze
pushing up its post- production schedule
by 4 and a half months Marvel films are
known for coming down to the wire given
Fig's ability to form the runway and
land the plane that way says one
executive familiar with how the company
operates but this level of Unfinished
was unprecedented and would be noted in
scathing reviews when the tent pole with
a $200 million budget opened 11 days
after the premiere critics weren't the
only ones dismayed fed up with 14 hour
days in no overtime Marvel VFX workers
voted unanimously to unionize in
September now as we know this eventually
led to the firing of Victoria Alonzo
with the article saying that she took
the fall due to the work conditions
being described as unsustainable The Log
Jam apparently began with She-Hulk which
underwent many changes including moving
one of the final episodes up to being
the first normally you'd have time to
work on these later episodes but that
shift them put them under more pressure
they also changed the designs of her too
causing even more disruptions on top of
this the budget spiraled out of control
as well with them saying that an episode
of she- hul costs more than the Game of
Thrones finale it's mental because it's
pretty much all shot on location in La
without some of the expansive costumes
or even half the CGI that that series
had Joanna Robinson also said there are
signs that the flood of products is
leading people to tune out I'm not
prepared to call it a permanent fall but
based on the numbers that go with Marvel
podcasts Marvel based articles friends
who do Marvel based videos coverage all
of those numbers are significantly down
I've seen that myself as well whereas my
lowy season 1 views were up near the
million this year we've not even broke
300K what you mean it's it's cuz the
videos are crap and I'm a terrible
YouTuber now I know there's been lots of
pressure behind the scenes with
corporate own channels too where the
stress of this is getting put on the
staff instead of what you know it being
the content's not as popular and p goes
on to talk about blade which when you
hear it absolutely mental says as public
criticism amounts f is pulling the plug
on scripts and projects that AR working
case in point the blade reboot with
Mersa Ali sign on for the epimist role
of the vampire it's it is EP pinous is
it things look promising for the 2023
release date but the project has gone
through at least five writers two
directors and one shut down 6 weeks
before production one person familiar
with the script permutation said the
story at one point morphed into a
narrative led by women and filled with
life blessons blade was relegated to the
fourth lead bizarre idea considering the
studio had two-time Oscar winner allei
on board only there was some TV show
that released this week with a perfect
meme for that if only anyway doing blade
and not making Blade the main character
uh that's that's just completely insane
to me Alli signed up to this film almost
immediately after winning an Oscar and
to put him on the back bench seems like
some Panda verse [__] sounds like
they've been using the stone to change
the script when you literally had the
easiest character to make a movie about
all you had to do is have manf fighting
vampires and there's absolutely no
reason to change it up and try and do it
another way I think Marvel's issue is
that they're bringing in a hell of a lot
of Indie filmmakers who have activism on
their mind when making these movies that
type of stuff yeah it works in an indie
setting but when it comes to Big
Blockbusters it often turns people off
so yeah just ridiculous and apparently
now they're aiming for a $100 million
budget personally I wouldn't be
surprised if Alli walks away and it also
talks about how he was ready to exit
over script issues blade was actually
meant to be released this week and it
shows how much they've managed to mess
it up now the last major part is that
Robert Downey Jr yeah Robert Downey Jr
and Scar Joe could be asked back to be
honest I always thought this was going
to be one of the main parts of Secret
Wars anyway and you might remember that
last year we dropped a big video over
what we'd heard on the film so far this
has turned out to be pretty bang on with
lots of scoopers backing it up and
basically they're going to be bringing
characters across from of the films and
then giving us a soft reboot now Griffin
shill actually made a really good point
they're talking about the desperation
clearly within the studio man said that
this is basically their legacy sequel
when they've not even hit the 208 Point
yeah and it shows how much the studio is
now panicking just use the panda Stone
mate make a Thor with Thor is a woman
never mind um make Iron Man with Iron
Man is oh never mind on that one as well
yeah shut up look shut up I like I like
Jane and iron heart mate I'm I'm just
trolling yeah don't hit the thumbs down
mate don't hit the don't be on cool and
hit the thumbs out what what do you mean
you hit it 5 minutes ago
anyway I personally think that both had
great send offs with RJ especially
getting the perfect one however Comics
be comics and there used to be a rule
that no one's really dead other than
Uncle Ben the Waynes and Gwen Stacy them
last two returned with the Multiverse
and I think they'll do the same thing
with the pair here I really don't think
it'll be the older versions and instead
I think it'll be multiversal variants of
them they did the same thing with Gora
but yeah kind of getting stupid that the
two people who died for the Soul Stone
are coming back could see an I see
though where Tony gets to see his
daughter grown up and maybe in his
Universe she died or something and and
they can do something like that anyway
this stuff we've been expecting it for a
long time and from what I've heard
Downey's actually been signed on for a
while now now personally I think they
just need to get the X-Men back in quick
and if you've heard the leaks about the
post credit scene for the Marvels then
you might have a fair inkling about
what's coming I've no idea why Marvel
got the rights back to them and then
they're still going ahead with some of
the side characters they are I think
Ekko is going to be a complete disaster
and and the the studio know it which is
why they've dropped it down to five
episodes and are releasing it all on day
one I have no idea why that was made in
the first place when the characters
never really had a massive following
anyway I think Guardians was both the
best and worst thing to happened in the
studio cuz it showed them they could
make projects out of any character but
that also doesn't mean they should make
projects out of every character if it
was me I would delay or cancel anything
they have now which isn't directly
Linked In with Secret Wars my big issue
is that Marvel just has so many
characters at the moment that there's
too many toys to play with in the
sandbox V is introducing people like The
Swordsman in Hawkeye when you know for a
fact nothing's going to happen with them
for at least a couple of years there's
just so many Side characters like there
that aren't going to go anywhere and it
makes it difficult to attach yourself to
the universe when there's so many
characters that nobody cares about you
think about phase one you get Iron Man
one he shows up an Incredible Hulk Iron
Man 2 Thor Captain America and then that
all comes together for for The Avengers
just slots together perfectly happens in
a nice time frame whereas now all these
characters who knows when they're going
to show now the perfect example is
Agatha she she had that hit with Agatha
all along but it's now going to be four
years since then when her shows drop I
don't think the interest was there and
though Katherine H's great I personally
don't think that this is going to be a
hit I imagine anyway now it seems like
Marvel is at least aware of this and as
we know Daredevils being reshot that
shows that they at least know where they
put a foot wrong and in my opin I just
scale it back just scale it back secret
Invasion that should have been its toown
phase and with the far from home post
credit SC I thought that would be the
case instead we had the horrendous Roy
reveal and the finale that's the lowest
rated MCU thing ever just a complete
mess and they really need to go back to
quality over quantity I think the way
they've handled Kang has been a bit of a
fumble and so far he's 0 and three
originally he was going to be Ant-Man
and qu Mania but they reshot the ending
to have him still lose stuff like this
just just robs him of being a thre and
I'm guessing he's getting thrown out
with last week's spaghetti now will I be
there day one for a new Avengers movie
absolutely I just hope they realize the
problems that they seem to have and go
ahead in a slightly altered Direction
obviously this is just one man's
thoughts though and I'd love to hear
yours in the comments below I personally
think you know we we've been sort of
touching upon this in the past on the
podcast and stuff there's hundreds of
videos out there talking about how
Marvel's doomed it's all doom and gloom
but for a mainstream article like
variety to be saying this you know
things are bad they obviously tend to
write puff pieces and yeah just for them
to be putting this out there it doesn't
seem good now please drop a like on the
video and if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out you want to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located below the video
with lots of tops including our brand
new Loki one now if you want something
else to watch you've got a video on
screen right now and definitely head
over there right after this out the way
huge thank you for sting through the
video I love you 3,000 I know I'm being
negative I do have positive feelings
about this though and yeah fingers
crossed it can all work out anyway I'll
see you next time and uh you take care
of yourself meet call you mate cuz
you're my
friend